[Music]
you all came highly
recommended you know the rules no real
names no Back
stories no sell so who's kidding is she
a very wealthy man who's about to be $50
million
poorer I'm here to make sure you're safe
what's your name mine's Abigail you can
call me Joey do you have any kids I have
a little boy see you in 24
hours do you know what a pinky promises
if you behave into as we
say like pinky promise you it'll all be
over soon Joey yeah I'm sorry about
what's going to happen to
you what the
[__] [__] we got to get out of
here I think she knows
something
guys
guys oh
no what the the [__] is that thing we
kidnapped a [__]
[Music]
vampire a ballerina
vampire okay how do we kill a vampire
what are we talking about like an an
rice or a True Blood you know Twilight
Stak through the heart daylight is a big
one all right let's go kill us a [__]
vampire
ready vampire on
[Music]
[Applause]
fire what can I say I like playing with
my
phone whoa whoa whoa she's [__]
[Music]
flying
I [__] hate
[Music]
ballet